pascal gros bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec tous sur rt france alors est
ce le début d'une nouvelle ère en
équateur selon vous avec l'arrivée de
guillermo la soie la tête du pays
en tout cas c'est le début d'une ère
pragmatique qui a décidé de placer en
effet l'économie au coeur d'un projet
pour le pays c'est la demande d'emploi
qui a gagné et non pas le débat
politique idéologique dans un pays vous
l'avez rappelé dans votre reportage qui
traversent des difficultés économiques
et sociales importantes
alors c'est vrai que le résultat de ces
élections il est tout à fait surprenant
puisque le premier tour avait en fait
placé andres araoz qui est arrivé
deuxième en tête à l'époque loin devant
le nouveau président de l'équateur
guillermo olaso alors que s'est-il passé
pendant ces deux tours pour que la
tendance s'inverse va l'économie a été
placé au coeur de ce projet pour pour
l'équateur un pays là aussi vous l'avez
rappelé un pays qui connaît la pandémie
qui en souffrent avec plus de 170 me
k340 mis le cap à revendre détecter et
17 mille morts mais évidemment une crise
économique une chute du pib de 8% dans
un pays où 40% de la population vit dans
le secteur informel donc véritablement
et c'est ça qui est intéressant dans une
amérique latine qui est impactée par
l'aco vide
c'est cette volonté de relance
économique
c'est cette demande d'emploi qui a été
au coeur de la problématique électorale
et qui a profité à l'isolation alors on
sait que guillermo olaso est adepte du
libre échange il vise un déficit zéro
pour ne pas aggraver la dette il a
également promis de créer 2000
on d'emploi une promesse tonna bhl selon
vous on verra dans la durée ce qui est
certain c'est que l'équateur c'est un
pays qui est au coeur du commerce
international premier producteur mondial
de bananes par exemple l'agriculture est
au coeur là aussi de la réalité
économique mais surtout pays pétroliers
pays
40% des ressources des revenus sont
tirés du pétrole
l'équateur c'est un pays qui est ouvert
sur la pêche et à travers cette
ouverture du pacifique vers l'asie
notamment d'un très gros producteur très
gros producteurs et pays intéressés par
la pêche notamment par le ton donc
l'équateur est au coeur du commerce
international et donc cette idée de
relance suppose évidemment des réformes
des réformes structurelles
quant aux mécanismes constitutionnels du
pays et viennent bien évidemment revenir
à l'essentiel à savoir l'économie les
infrastructures ne désenclavement de
certaines régions dans le pays
bref un projet global de relance site
vitale alors même que l'équateur à
poupet à pau voisins la colombie et le
pérou eux-mêmes aujourd'hui engagés dans
cette lutte contre la pandémie et avec
des économies qui sont évidemment au
ralenti alors guillermo olaso va
succéder à l'impopulaire lenin moreno le
mois prochain à part l'économie et
l'emploi quels sont les principaux défis
qui l'attendent
naturellement l'environnement
l'environnement en équateur c'est au
coeur de l'économie et guillermo olaso
le président élu de l'équateur va je
crois devoir tenir compte de certaines
orientations certains certains axes qui
avaient été définis par yacou perez
yakou perez c'est un leader indien qui
était d'ailleurs arrivé troisième au
premier tour des élections et qui avec
patch ou pachakutik son parent
s'ils avaient fait des propositions
importantes pour une prise en compte de
l'environnement
mais il se servir de cette problématique
comme un des facteurs de la relance
économique donc véritablement cette
orientation va être sans doute là aussi
au coeur de cette transformation
économique qui est une des résultantes
de la pandémie de la cofidis touch qui
frappent l'équateur comme elle sera très
fortement l'amérique latine merci
beaucoup
pascal drouhaud d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'association france
amérique latine